deborah james won the hearts of the
country dancing through her cancer
treatment with humor and candor even in
her final days she raised millions for
cancer charities the consultants who
cared for her called her achievements
unparalleled
she made a difference to to patients
with cancer
she
debunked the whole myth of of cancer and
what it might mean
i'll remember as somebody who gave
incredible hope to many many people in
this country i can't go out
i'm
sick deborah james used her social media
platform bowel babe to break the taboos
of cancer her podcast you me in the big
c propelled the deputy head teacher to
fame her final episode was recorded
after she'd begun end of life care
i feel like i've been you know playing
with the devil and i think
you know we think oh no it's caught up
with me now um
i've i haven't really got my head around
this
her podcast producer mike holt spoke of
his love for deborah i'll miss her i'll
miss her more than anything else i'll
miss her you know she'll she'll my phone
will ring any time of the day and when i
look down i see it's deborah i'll think
wow what's this going to be next you
know what's going to what's the next
idea debs
and
i'll miss her
bowel cancer is the fourth most common
and second deadliest cancer in the uk
less talked about than other forms often
seen as embarrassing debra broke that
stigma she used her experience to tackle
the taboos of cancer raise awareness of
bowel cancer signs and symptoms but also
has been a powerful advocate for
uh research and for the charity it was
obviously never my intention to kind of
die before his release which i'm really
glad
even in her last few weeks she didn't
stop raising over 1 million pounds
through the launch and sale of her
fashion line basically from now on
[Music]
deborah announced her second book
one she won't now see published and
celebrated what she described as perfect
moments with her family through hospice
care at home and a deteriorating
condition even a trip to the opera at
glenborn her last visit there was five
years ago newly
[Music]
shirt diagnosed often dressed up to
spread the word for people to get
checked for bowel cancer that remains
her overriding message
deborah james didn't waste a moment of
her 40 years her relentless campaigning
will undoubtedly save the lives of
others awarded a dame hood in her final
weeks a show of appreciation from a
nation who loved her
i suppose
that's it from me i can't believe it
that that is it for me
enjoy life because it is so precious
it's
all i want right now is more time and
more life
um
and
oh and also check your p
adele robinson sky news